bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de la voie est libre nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui une émission
spéciale consacrée aux six premiers mois
de notre région bourgogne franche comté
avec vous et mexique où vous nous
présenter nos invités et euh oui
effectivement il est autour de la table
effectivement nous avons réuni trois
invités à commencer par marie-guite
dufay
c'est vous qui présidait cette région
bourgogne franche comté depuis le 4
janvier dernier face à vous deux
opposantes catherine vandriesse bonjour
vous êtes membre de l'est république à
vous représentez ici le groupe de droite
du centre ac que qui compte 25 élus au
conseil régional
sophie montel bonjour vous présidez le
groupe front national un groupe qui
compte 24 conseillers régionaux alors
marie-guite dufay la première question
est pour vous forcément en janvier
dernier vous manqué votre élection dès
le premier tour de la présidence puisque
vos deux conseillers régionaux du parti
radical de gauche attendent le deuxième
taux pour voter pour vous puis vous
votez des hausses qui font mal à des
mythes et des aigus et cartes grises
polémique
puis vous proposez que le siège du
conseil régional soit situé à besançon
et non pas à dijon polémique
et puis cette semaine les frac les fonds
régionaux d'art contemporain font la une
de l'actualité puisque françois patriat
l'ancien président socialiste de la
région bourgogne vous accuse de vouloir
saborder le frac de bourgogne dites-nous
franchement entre nous ces six premiers
mois vous les aviez pas rêver comme ça
je ne sais pas si j'avais de toute façon
on rêvait à ses six premiers mois
ce dont je rêve moi c'est de réussir à
faire ce que je me suis engagé de faire
trois priorités l'emploi améliorer
absolument nous sommes exactement et
fait ses premiers mois rue c'est
l'occasion écologique et la
participation citoyenne
les choix ont été difficiles c'est
fait partie de ça fait partie des choses
vous dirai pas que c'est facile ou que
c'est difficile pour moi ça fait partie
du job
bah oui ben oui mais vous attendiez à ce
que ce soit aussi compliqué quand même
mais ce qui est compliqué pour moi c'est
de réussir à mettre en place les trois
priorités que je me suis fixé c'est ça
pendant toutes les polémiques que vous
venez de citer
pendant ce temps là j'ai une équipe qui
travaille et nous nous attelons au
travail donc pour moi c'est ça le plus
important c'est la solidité de mon
équipe et c'est la façon dont nous
avançons sur nos engagements sur le
reste j'ai tendance à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de polémiques la
polémique pour moi c'est plutôt les
qu'une des choses on va y revenir
catherine vandriesse comment vous jugez
vous ce début de mandat
on a vu des films d'ouverture notamment
avec alain joyandet qui préside la
commission des finances est ce que ça
vous convient cette façon de fonctionner
de la présidente et de son équipe sur
l'ouverture et la présidence de cette
commission
c'est quelque chose qui est devenu on va
dire presque rituelle attendant le
fonctionnement démocratique donc très
bien par contre les silences de madame
buffet à l'instant sur les six premiers
mois je pense que c'est la réponse
qu'elle peut donner effectivement ses
six premiers mois ont été difficiles il
ya le couac de l'élection je rappelle
également il faut aussi que nos
concitoyens le sachant votre élection
elle s'est faite sur 20 % des inscrits
réellement voilà donc on est aujourd'hui
dans un mode de fonctionnement politique
mais ça aurait été la même chose s'y
greffe entre son modèle et aider oui
mais s'ils voulaient ce qui me gêne plus
c'est que la particularité madame duflot
c'est que c'est elle est présidente
sortante de la région franche comté le
président patriat avec madame buffet
nous explique depuis 2014 que la fusion
est quelque chose d'important et que
vous étiez parmi les régions en avance
si ce que je regrette bien dans le
constat de la réalité parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez nous allons
vous avez présenté un budget 2016 de
transition où il n'y a pas d'action
réellement tourné sur la priorité qu'ils
emploient d'autres régions avance et je
me suis permis juste quelque chose hier
soir avant de venir je suis allé
consulter le site
alors ne voyez pas de polémique
politique le site de la région
ile-de-france pourquoi parce que vous
savez on a deux particularités entrant
frotter en bombe franche comté nous
sommes parmi les plus petites régions en
terme de pib et de population
et nous sommes un pays écartelé entre
l'île de france et la région rhône alpes
auvergne
lorsque vous allez consulter le site
internet qui est la première vitrine
aujourd'hui qu'on donne d'une activité
d'une collectivité de la région ile de
france
qu'est ce qui met en avant les projets
de développement économique sur les
start-up les projets d'adèle et
d'adossement aux entreprises sur des
nouveaux fonds développer les
présentations extrêmement clair
extrêmement synthétique et il ya
également l'agenda de valérie pécresse
sur ses activités en tant que présidente
et sa volonté développement économique
de sa région
alors qui peut le plus peut le moins
évidemment c'est la région ile de france
ont su aller chercher votre agenda sur
sites de la région bourgogne compliqué
d'accès madame quand france 3 franche
comté je vous en parlais occupé dachser
ne trouve pas et je vais pas vous le
sortir parce que je suis quelqu'un de
bien élever la page est blanche
on n'a aucune visibilité soufflerie fait
même sur le site internet et lorsque
vous regardez la page de garde ce que ça
va être peut-être l'objet du débat
d'aujourd'hui la page de garde du sud
bourgogne franche comté vous avez raison
madame 80% des actions qui sont relatés
qui me suivent des actions du territoire
de franche comté dont j'ai un peu contre
la fusion on va donner la parole à
sociaux elle prend quand même on va en
parler ce sera la honte elle est cabré
agenda soit blanc cela m'étonne quand
même parce que je suis étonné de la
façon dont on me rends compte de tous
mes déplacements et je vois tu sont
archiconnus donc je pense que mon agenda
de votre jeune âge internet interne
attendant mon canada n'est pas blanc et
battre avec votre service communication
ryan alors madame ont-elles vous comment
jugez vous ses six premiers mois on ne
vit que la présidente vous avez pas
exclue notamment à 10 des conseils
d'administration des lycées comme ça a
été le cas par le passé ce que vous vous
êtes plutôt satisfait du déroulement de
ces six premiers mois concernant
l'entrée des élus du front national dans
les conseils d'administration des lycées
ou des organismes extérieurs
je dois dire qu'au vu des résultats que
nous avons obtenus au moment des
régionales notamment le front national
était quand même la liste que je conduis
j'ai quand même arrivé en tête au soir
du premier tour il faut dire que nous
sommes une région où front national a
failli l'emporter ça s'est joué dans un
film donc gg je note que la présidente
socialiste à respecter le choix des
urnes est qu'il n'ya pas eu de positions
sectaires notamment en excluant les élus
du front national des conseils
d'administration c'est une autre c'est
un c'est une décision que j'ai salué
mais pour moi c'est l'application de la
démocratie et le respect du résultat des
urnes
il faut aussi noter que effectivement il
ya eu un certain nombre de couacs de
dysfonctionnements il faut faire la
distinction à mon sens entre les
dysfonctionnements de fonctionnement
plus c'est à dire l'organisation
administrative parce que les socialistes
comme ceux comme l'ump d'ailleurs
combats étaient traîtres de deux grands
opposants à cette à cette fusion des
régions voulue par les socialistes pour
nous a quand même vendu les socialistes
nous ont vendu la fusion comme source
d'économie on s'aperçoit dans la réalité
que ce ne sera absolument pas le cas il
ya effectivement la mise en route de la
fusion au niveau administratif donc ça
on peut on peut pardonner parce que je
me suis quand même mis quelques mois un
instant à ce niveau là dans la place de
la présidente si j'avais été élu
effectivement au niveau administratif
on peut concevoir qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de choses qui doivent se mettre
en route et tout ça donc ça ça peut
s'excuser à condition bien évidemment
que ça ne dure pas sûr sur la durée du
monde mais maintenant effectivement il
ya des problèmes qui sont des problèmes
politiques il ya eu des choix politiques
qui à mon sens n'ont pas été les bons
notamment l'augmentation des indemnités
notamment logo parle de l'augmentation
des indemnités des élus mais aussi
l'augmentation des indemnités des
membres du cesoc il ya eu aussi
l'augmentation de la taxe sur les
certificats moi en tant que vendons
soirée la carte grise bateau on voyage 4
soit des pays en tant que l'on fait
quand même peser sur les francs comtois
rond va leur demander de contribuer à
hauteur de 17 millions d'euros ce qui
n'est quand même pas rien pour en
réalité parce qu'on va le voir au mois
de juin on va avoir la présentation des
comptes administratifs des deux régions
séparés pour s'apercevoir qu'en réalité
les francs comtois vous quand même
mettre la main à la poche pour payer les
dettes des bourguignons parce que la
gestion patriat quand même été une
gestion très dispendieuse alors
j'entends aujourd'hui effectivement vous
parlez vous parlez des frac monsieur
patriat n'est pas satisfait de la
gestion des frac voulue par madame du
fait je crois qu'en réalité le fond
c'est que monsieur patriat n'a tout
simplement pas digéré de ne pas avoir
été investi à la tête et ça ça fait
partie de la soupe interne des élus
socialistes
il ya effectivement aussi au niveau
politique des couacs dans le sens où
madame buffet n'a pas été élu dès le
premier tour il ya elle a une majorité
très faible ça va aussi ceux constatés
lors du mans
au moyen du vote effet sommaire des
décès merci pour son but est de parler
beaucoup de ma majorité qui est très
faible
ça je ne peux pas le contester cma
majorité soit faible ce qui est
important c'est qu'elle soit soudé c'est
qu'elles soient unis c'est qu'elle est
en vie c'est qu'elle est en vie moi je
suis extrêmement fier et ça a été
découvert pour moi de réaliser que
pendant les élections
l'équipe qui est autour de moi c'était
soudé avait vraiment fait connaissance
et avait envie il y a une envie je crois
qu'il vient du fait que cette équipe
profondément renouvelée
beaucoup de jeunes qui ne ménagent pas
leur peine
et moi je suis extrêmement fier de cette
majorité
alors elle est pourtant mais elle est
solide
alors justement l'un de vos fidèles a
annoncé qu'ils démissionnaient cette
saison vit pardon il avait moison blida
a priori moins envie ou alors ils
avaient plus envie de l'agglomération du
pays de montbéliard c'est denis sommer
qui était donc une pièce maîtresse dans
votre dispositif il était vice président
chargé de l'économie
il occupe est déjà assez fou que cette
fonction-là lors de votre précédent
mandat quand vous étiez présidente du
conseil régional de franche comté
c'est quand même un petit peu un désaveu
pour vous qu'il s'en aille
non non je ne le prends pas du tout
comme ça et les relations que nous avons
sont des relations il ne se situe pas du
tout à ces niveaux-là de nice au maire
depuis de longs mois hésite
il sait ce que vous avez imposées ou fx
peuvent être alors qu elle voilà le
monde que deux pour se mettre en
conformité avec la charte éthique que
j'ai imposé à mes élus qui fait qu'on va
y avoir cumul de mandat d'exécutif il ne
peut pas être à la fois à bp dans une
agglomération evp à la région
vice-président pardon dont il sait qu'il
a à faire un choix est ce choix a été
compliqué pour des raisons internes
essentiellement aux pays de montbéliard
et puis petit à petit il ya aussi des
choses nouvelles qui arrivent sur le
pays de montbéliard may be ne l'espère
au modjo lyautey d'agglomération venir
précis
à bouger donc voilà vous le regrettez
quand même qu'il s'en aille ou pas je
regrette qu'il ne soit plus vice
président chargé de l'économie
mais il reste dans mon équipe et je vais
en profiter pour demander à jean claude
lagrange qui était son homologue en
bourgogne dans le mandat précédent qui
donc connaît extrêmement le sujet qui
vient d'une paire industriel lui aussi
puisqu'il vient du creusot de
effectivement prendre sa place avec une
équipe de conseillers délégués renforcée
autour de lui si je ne m'abuse jean
claude lagrange est aussi vice-président
de la communauté urbaine cru que vous là
s'il le fait c'est qu'il va démissionner
de sa vice-présidence de prison montceau
bien évidemment je joue quand même
cette charte que s'est imposée de non
cumul c'est un exemple unique en france
alors je veux bien entendre toutes les
polémiques ce serait bien aussi qu'on
puisse se dire de temps en temps tient
en termes d'exercice vertueux il ya à
regarder il ya une expérience elle peut
être complétée je dis pas que c'est
parfait mais nous avons commencé à
établir des règles et notamment de non
cumul d'exécutif pour une raison de
disponibilité à part entière au service
des fonctions que nous avons amené à la
région mesdames vous souhaitez réagir
les hommes d'andré s on est tellement
dans une urgence dans la compétence
régalienne dont vous avez parlé madame
tout à l'heure que le développement
économique et l'emploi que sur ses
compétences fly sur ces délégations qui
sont juste les dégâts sont fondamentales
on peut pas dans un amateurisme deux
fois la fusion on en a parlé et laissez
moi juste terminée la fusion est
compliqué et même si vous l'aviez entamé
il ya plus d'un an et demi on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui finalement ces
travaux d'un an et demi ne donnent pas
les résultats souhaités
donc ça c'est vraiment un souci est que
nous avons et dont on a par ailleurs
régulièrement session mais sur les
désignations de vaud vice président sur
ses fonctions régaliennes de la région
vous auriez quand même pu anticiper la
carte politique je sais que vous
connaissez parfaitement bien pour pas
avoir si vous voulez ces ajustements
démarrage mais les six mois qu'on a
perdu aujourd'hui c'est les six mois qui
vont suivre encore demain on est en plus
en période de vacances mais vu le temps
passer
les blues se fait avant nous n'avons
rien perdu explique dans un exécutif qui
est pas en place
hélas nous n'avons aujourd'hui mais a
perdu vous avez vous même participé à
l'assemblée budgétaire vous avez vu
combien sur le plan économique nous
avons mis un budget positif est
conséquent pour démarrer dès maintenant
la convergence des politiques il y à une
mesure que les entreprises attendent
aujourd'hui parce que en période de
chômage comme nous connaissons que nous
connaissons il ya aussi un problème de
recrutement de la part des entreprises
on a le ce double problème d'un chômage
intolérable et d'énormes difficultés de
recrutement des entreprises
aujourd'hui les entreprises attendent
qu'on les aide effectivement par rapport
à ces problèmes d'orientation et de
recrutement nous avons décidé d'étendre
à toute la bourgogne un système qui
fonctionnait bien avant en franche comté
et qui permet de former des demandeurs
d'emploi sur des postes de travail
à partir du moment où il y a une
promesse d'embauché et ça c'est une aide
que les entreprises effectivement
attendent à bras ouverts nous prenons
les moyens dès maintenant
mais bien sûr que j'y fasse nous avons
voté non elle n'est pas en main
aujourd'hui est méritant intrusion il me
faut ce qu elle est en place je le vaux
même à dire 100 g de professionnels de
dire ça nous méritons classe vient de
façon à la professionnalisation et
redemander après le vote du budget fin
avril ce dépôt une seconde
imada mantel vous vouliez réagir ça
durera pas une seconde non j'ai demandé
une seconde à marie-guite dufay
voilà je voulais réagir on était sur le
avant de partir sur les problèmes
économiques que je sois là nous
aborderons évidemment sur le cumul
alors madame j'entends avec buffet se
parler de sa charte éthique pas de cumul
entre des exécutifs et tout ça vous
prenez l'exemple de monsieur sommaire je
crois savoir qu'il est toujours maire de
grand charmont
donc il est déjà à la tête d'un exécutif
il va certes laisser sa vice présidence
au conseil régional mais il reste
conseiller régional il sera aussi vice
président à la communauté d'agglo et
vous l'avez rappelé il vise en fait la
tête de cette communauté d'agglomération
beaune est mêlé harry dans la joie mais
ça féret il est toujours à la tête de
trois files qui cumule toujours trois
mandats
parce que vous savez comme moi dans le
calcul des molécules dans l'histoire du
cumul des mandats l'intercommunalité
comme par hasard ne rentre pas on a
aussi un autre spécialiste au conseil
régional
parce que je ne souhaite pas comment
dire m'acharne et non plus uniquement
sur les socialistes on a aussi un
exemple type chez les républicains on à
françois sauvadet qui avait promis de
démissionner au mois de septembre 2015
ce qui les attendait il est actuellement
conseiller régional président du conseil
départemental de côte-d'or et nous
sommes en juin et il n'a toujours pas
démissionner de son mandat de député et
il est donc encore député à l'assemblée
nationale où il n'est d'ailleurs pas
très présent puisque chacun pourra
constater regarder sur le site nos
députés l'assiduité de monsieur sauvadet
n'est pas terrible depuis plus d'une
année déjà
il a menti monsieur souhaité non
évidemment s'il a menti il a pas menti
c'est tout le monde c'est au tour de
table les raisons pour lesquelles il est
toujours député fait dur qui a été
entamée de recours contre les élections
sur les greens explosions séparées par
un gaulliste non mais c'est pas la
question et à une paix durable sera pire
actuellement si suspens quand même
madame ont-elles les émois répondre moi
je voudrais pas vous êtes chez vous et
que vous vous êtes supporter vous savez
ni le bien pourquoi monsieur klein a
déposé le confort cela permet à monsieur
sauvadet
je joue les écoute et je ne reviendrai
pas sur la sur ce que vous avez fait en
a semblé qu'il n'ya pas lui suspendre
avec vos modes de communication qui eux
ne sont pas démocratiques un tout à fait
donc non sauf que c'est pas la manière
si vous les avez eu peur de petites en
jeu prend une forme de petites panthères
de maintenance et on fait la même chose
mais vous allez arriver s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît vous êtes vraiment
acharnée sur le cassonade et donc il ya
un recours qui a été fait il ya recours
qui a été fait sur concernant ces
élections régionales ce recours suspend
les propos que vous savez parfaitement
et si aujourd'hui et si aujourd'hui
françois sauvadet démissionner de son
mandat il n'y aurait plus de députés sur
cette circonscription jusqu'aux
prochaines élections législatives et
cinq ans avait voilà donc maintenant à
la situation elle est comme elle est la
position qu'il a eue elle il l'a eu
et aujourd'hui il renaît dans un cadre
administratif qui donne qui finalement
lui permettre un bon mandat fait plus de
deux en tout cas qu'une représentation
parlementaire sur cette séquence est un
peu contre eux on ne peut pas répondre à
la question c'est fabien qui nous poser
cette question de quand la démission
promis ce temps monsieur durée des plans
ici je peux pour mesure de vous répondre
je peux vous donner en tout cas une
explication administratives et de ses
pannes jusqu'aux tu précises qu'on
l'avait bien invité puisqu'il s'était
aussi une partie de la question des
femmes y en avait un qui me souvenais
mais pour des raisons d'agenda
il n'a pas pu se rendre disponible au
regard si catherine vandriesse d'être
présente ce matin on passe à un autre
sujet de la scène catherine le coup du
diable vous l'aviez évoqué tout à
l'heure le coo de j voilà l'ancien
président de la région bourgogne
françois patriat qui dénonce la
disproportion des moyens alloués par le
nouveau conseil régional au frac de
franche comté par rapport au frac de
bourgogne à 85 % des fonds pour le
premier contre 4 pour le second du coup
le président du frac bourgogne claude
patriat qui est le frère et de françois
c'est compliqué a démissionné à 6 ans
avant d'en parler je vous propose de
regarder le reportage de sylvain billau
et jean louis st
peut-être la fin de l'entente cordiale
entre marc et du fait et françois
patriat
dans un communiqué l'ancien président du
conseil régional de bourgogne sort de sa
réserve et critique la politique de
subvention de la présidente de la grande
région en matière culturelle
il pointe le déséquilibre entre les 1
million 700 mille euros allouée au frac
de franche comté
les trois cent cinquante mille euros
versée à celui de bourgogne un montant
jugé insuffisant pour le responsable du
frac basé à dijon au regard des
investissements engagés pour la création
d'une réserve
claude patriat le frère de l'ancien
président de région a donc préféré
démissionner même s'il est conscient que
les deux frappes n'ont pas la même
taille
moi je n'étais pas du tout partisan
de d'enlever des moyens de répartir 50
50 entre les deux mais qu' il y ait à
cette occasion dans les limites
budgétaires qui sont celles de la région
et que je comprends tout à fait qu'il y
ait donné au frac bourgogne le quad
réaliser de quoi réaliser son projet ce
qui visiblement n'était pas la volonté
des nouveaux il pour la présidence de la
grande région n'est pas question de
guéguerre entre la franche comté et la
bourgogne
c'est d'ailleurs une élue bourguignonne
qui vient s'en expliquer selon la vice
présidente en charge de la culture ce
refus d'augmenter les subventions est
justifiée par une alerte du commissaire
aux comptes et à des problèmes de
fonctionnement au sein du frac de
bourgogne
on demande à tous la même chose de
travailler en cohérence intelligemment
on demande pas d'effusion partout on ne
demande pas de colin mange l'autre c'est
pas du tout ça le sujet c'est de faire
en sorte de connaître son voisin c'est
le minimum de savoir ce qui est fait
pour travailler en cohérence et en bonne
intelligence donc c'est ce qui a été
demandé aux deux fera qu est ce qui n'a
pas été possible jusque là et ce qui va
l'être maintenant on l'espère dossiers
politiques ou querelles de personnes
l'avenir du frac de bourgogne pourrait
donc s'éclaircir avec un nouveau
président catherine vandriesse je
m'adresse à vous puisque vous êtes
dijonnais est vrai bourguignonne vous
comprenez la colère des deux patries
comprends la colère et je comprends
surtout que la fusion socialiste c'était
une promesse d'économies d'un milliard
d'économies
c'est ça le cahier des charges de notre
plan d'affaires pour la france pour la
france évidemment je passe de notre
budget de la meilleure froid précisé
pour les jambes ce qu on balance d'ici
là deux milliards c'est quand même un
chiffre difficile à appréhender le
budget de la bourgogne franche comté
c'est 23 milliards la réforme des
fusions des régions politiquement dans
un argument qui était donné par le parti
socialiste était entre autres deux
permettre de générer des économies de
l'ordre de 20 milliards d'euros pour
au niveau national madame du fait
pendant votre campagne vous avez rêvé de
ça plusieurs reprises un plus un égale 3
on est d'accord
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte que un
plus un effectivement et là on parle pas
du frac l'air un monsieur désert venir
au frac que un plus un égale 3 et toutes
les limites de la fusion parce que la
logique les dracs ont fusionné
la logique ça serait que le frac huiyan
on est dans une logique aussi d'économie
alors autant le développement culturel
et touristique c'est réellement un
argument de développement économique
donc là dessus je pense que on doit se
retrouver autour de cette table
c'est-à-dire que vous voulez pas que le
budget culture donc le budget frappe
soit diminuée je sais pas ce que je suis
en train de vous dire qu'on veut dire
que quand on est dans une perspective
réellement de fusion on doit générer des
économies et moi je ne trouve pas normal
qu'aujourd'hui dans ce fonctionnement
des deux fera qu il ya une dotation tu
sois plus importante de manière
significative pour l'un et qui est pas
réellement une volonté de fusion
pourquoi est ce qu'on arrive pas on va
sonner un schéma en forme on va le faire
dans comptez pas sur tout sujet pour
l'instant
un braquage et on le fait on va entendre
aussi la position de ce film hôtel pour
le front national vous l'art
contemporain général au front national
c'est un sujet sur lequel il reste assez
abrupte à moi je me souviens très bien
de la visite de madame lebranchu en mai
2014 qui était venu expliquer à l'époque
on parlait pas de fusion il était venu
expliquer les bienfaits d'une
coopération intensive entre entre les
régions et je lui j'avais été très
surprise parce que je lui avais posé la
question des économies elle m'avait déjà
dit à l'époque il n'était pas question
de faire des économies là n'était pas la
question
elle avait présenté un projet concernant
la bourgogne franche comté avaient
d'ailleurs été assez surprise elle avait
dit vous avez par exemple un fracas
besançon vous avez un fracas dijon ce
serait pas mal d'avoir un troisième
donc le problème du frac des frac en
général c'est tout simplement les frais
de fonctionnement parce que vous savez
que moi que il ya très peu de visiteurs
en dehors des 48 heures d'écart et ses
colères oui en dehors des cars scolaires
qu'on envoie trois quatre fois dans
l'année et les frac
il ya quand même un problème de fond sur
les oeuvres en général qui sont exposés
il faudrait quand même réfléchir à ça si
on va attirer du monde moi je suis je le
dis et je le répète nous sommes pour un
art populaire et pour effectivement
quand on a des structures comme ça il
faut il faut essayer de faire en sorte
que les gens soient attirés et à y
découvrir les oeuvres
nos artistes frac mais sous les 2 pour
adéquat sur les deux phrases d'ailleurs
je crois qu'ils ne sont pas d'ailleurs
les que ça soit celui de bourgogne
franche comté ne sont pas sous le même
statut juridique donc la faire fusionner
c'est assez particulier
je moi je ça m'amuse en réalité parce
que aujourd'hui vous avez il ya quand
même un problème de fond un problème est
éthique j'allais dire un problème en
tout cas peut-être de conflit d'intérêts
quelque chose dans ce goût là
aujourd'hui vous allez quand vous l'avez
dit vous avez le frère de monsieur
patriat ancien président du conseil
régional de bourgogne qui est à la tête
du frac le vrac des finances et les
coffee nylon théo les kills à des mises
à jour il vient de démissionner
seulement maintenant vous avez dans
votre reportage expliqué que le frac de
bourgogne était quand même sous les feux
de la cour des comptes ce qui tend à
démontrer qu'il ya quand même eu des
dépenses
le frac visiblement de bourgoin n'a pas
été malheureux sous l'ère patriat alors
qu'aujourd'hui et à rajuster
réajustement je vais pas pleurer sur le
frac de bourgogne parce qu'aujourd'hui
on leur donne un tour de vis qui parlait
toujours du nécessaire équilibre entre
les deux régions non mais là sur des
sujets comme ça moi si vous voulez
contient une structure qui a été comment
dire peut-être suralimenté
financièrement en tout cas qui n'a pas
été maltraité durant la mandature de
monsieur patriat
je vais pas pleurer aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya un tour de vis au contraire je
je ne peux que m'en féliciter si on tend
à faire des économies
madame du fait donc là les patriat
françois et claude c'est quand même un
caillou dans votre chaussure écouter sur
les fera qu il y a deux équipes en
france comptait en mongol qui sont
formidables les deux pour organiser une
programmation des programmations qui
permettent d'attirer de plus en plus de
monde sur cet art y est pas facile hein
de da proches
il y a une vraie volonté d'aller vers le
public et je pense qu'on peut faire
ensemble de belles et bonnes choses mais
avant de faire cela ensemble que ça soit
sous forme de fusion ou d'une autre
façon duras des moyens qui seront
mutualisés c'est évident il y aura des
programmations commune y aura des
expositions communes
il va y avoir une synergie entre ces
deux étapes les âmes les onze ans et l'a
340 euros
avant cela il faut assainir les
situations et nous avons hambourg
veulent une situation où il y avait un
problème et de gestion et de gouvernance
je ne la vente pas ce sont les faits
donc il faut assainir cette situation là
et à partir du moment où elle sera
assainie nous allons travailler c'est
déjà en cours jeudi il ya deux équipes
formidables à la tête je parle des
équipes scientifiques des équipes
artistiques qui sont à la tête de ces
deux phrases qui sont en train de
trouver les moyens de travailler
ensemble mais il fallait que la
situation soit assaini et en bourgogne
c'est pas une question que la france
comptait plus doté que la bourgogne
c'est que le frac de bourgogne qui est
installée dans des locaux beaucoup moins
conséquent que ceux de la france comté
où il y a eu ce grand geste et cette
grande volonté du président fort ni de
poser un bâtiment est extrêmement
important il y à hambourg bonn une
situation à assainir qui sera à mon avis
rapide qui sera rapidement vous engager
sur des délinquants mais un peu de
perspective sur ce sur ce type de
dossier car faisant des cas dames nancy
masse mais quitter pour vous avant
quelle échéance si on sera assainie
d'ici la fin de l'année renault à cette
fameuse ce début de demander à un peu
compliqué avec notamment la fin la
fameuse augmentation de 20 % des
indemnités des élus vous aurez beaucoup
expliqué est ce que quand même vous
n'avez pas pris le mesure du choc que ça
a pu provoquer il ya eu notamment une
pétition signée par près de vingt mille
personnes me semble-t-il du chiffre est
ce que vous aviez pris la mesure de deux
effectives mans cela prendrait une
importance pareil mais moi vous savez
quand vous êtes alors en décalage avec
la population si vous mesuriez pas ça
prend une importance telle par contre
j'avais mesuré qu'il y aurait une
opposition et je l'assumé complètement
parce qu'il me semblait que c'était le
moyen d'avoir un vrai débat sur qu'est
ce qu'on attend d'un début et moi je
pense que les élus effectivement surtout
à la région ou en plus les sujets sont
extrêmement complexes nécessitent
énormément disponibilité mais il faut
organiser les choses pour que les élus
puissent
à arrêter momentanément leur travail
leur activité professionnelle et il faut
qu'ils aient des indemnités conséquentes
inconscient se contenta sélectivement
est passé de 1900 à 2200 80 euros soit
une augmentation de presque 400 euros
pour un conseiller régional est dans une
phase où l'on brut
oui et pendant ce temps là il arrête son
activité professionnelle il se met en
disponibilité en actions soit diminuée
sortie mais pas forcément la plupart la
plupart de mes vice-présidents et le
talent des vice-présidents que je passe
d'un style à un vice présidents tous les
3100 fort intéressant rutte
je rappelle que dans ma majorité j'ai
donné des responsabilités à quasiment
l'ensemble de ma majorité soit au
vice-président sans conseiller délégué
ce qui leur demande énormément de temps
et je plaide pour qu'ils aient les
moyens de faire cela et je rappelle
quand même que à l'échelle de toute la
france cette indemnité
une fois révisé une fois augmenté et la
plus faible de toutes les régions de
france d'affairé jeu votre opposition
manoeuvre andries quand même et si vous
vous avez voté contre alors groupe de
droite mais est ce que c'était pas quand
même démagogique puisque avant les
conseillers régionaux touché on savait
une prime parce qu'ils participaient
tous à la commission permanente
sk pas un peu de démagogie dans le fait
d'avoir voté contre cette augmentation
qui relativement faible mais qui était
prévu par la loi
lorsqu'on s'est réuni dans notre groupe
pour décider notre position notre
décision à l'avenir prendre entre 20 et
30 secondes
parce que quand on sort d'une campagne
électorale comme celle que nous avons
vécue puis jour même si en perspective
les attentes on est vraiment dans une
taille particulièrement difficile quand
vous nous expliquer madame que ce qui
est plus important aujourd'hui c'est
l'emploi et qu'on ne perçoit pas le
décalage que vous avez évoqué ya
quelques secondes sur la difficulté des
français et l'incohérence de proposer
une augmentation d'un pour cent en
regard des difficultés économiques
voilà la réponse est là d'autant que on
vient d'en parler là depuis la quart
d'heure
quasiment tous vos élus sont au cumul de
mandats la vraie question de fond mais
j'aimerais qu'on pose un jour en france
fait preuve de la 6e à plus excitant
non mais c'est pas une en cours des
mandats qui ne rentrent pas dans tous
les mandats donc ils ont pas de
rémunération seulement liée à leurs
fonctions de conseiller régional et la
brésil et ses voisins il a ré ouvert la
question ont fait la nation il faut il
faut que telle est attelé d'été spector
le sachent le seul groupe politique
qu'ils se soient opposés
clairement on vote on court sur cette
délibération c'est nous c'est à dire le
groupe des républicains du centre et la
droite le front national
il ya une position qui est l'abstention
madame sur un sujet comme celui-ci c'est
claire c'est oui ou non quand ça tu
tiens séduire ou indirectement pas du
tout revenir sur ce qui est notre
position elle est extrêmement clair la
deuxième chose
vous avez raison il ya un vrai problème
ce statut de l'élu joint chef
d'entreprise ya pas de salariés dans les
représentations les assemblées pas de
salariés du monde privée pire que 20 30
40 50% dans certains territoires
c'est un vrai problème de
représentativité donc il ya un problème
de fond sur la position des élus et leur
visibilité près par rapport au grand
public il ya votre décision qui est un
décalage absolue avec la réalité du
terrain et la perception de l'élu il ya
notre position unique qui était de voter
contre et qui était pas simplement comme
vous présentez un gadget politique parce
que c'est une conviction de fonds elles
ont construit de la conviction pour
conviction considère qu'aujourd'hui
c'est insupportable et mal élevé 23
mille signataires de la pétition madame
sur internet 23 mille signataires qui
vous ont alerté sur le fait qu'
aujourd'hui en 2016
on ne peut pas tolérer ce qui a été fait
ce que nous avons nous assumer par nos
cliniciens trice de la pétition que j'ai
rencontré m'a dit qu'elle comprenait
parfaitement l'augmentation pour les
vice présidents et les conseillers
délégués que c'était pour l'ensemble des
conseillers a maintenant c'est pas
normal que l'opposition touche autant
alors
je ne peux pas faire de différence entre
un conseiller qui n'a pas de
responsabilité un conseiller en à madame
vandriesse madame vandriesse votre parti
politique vous parler du statut de l'élu
votre parti politique à diriger les
affaires de la france pendant de
nombreuses années et n'a pas mis en
place un statut
voilà et puis vous avez oublié aussi de
rappeler à sophie montel qu'elle aussi
elle cumule puisqu'elle est donc au
parlement européen
vous vouliez dire quoi à propos de ses
habilités qui souhaite vous êtes abstenu
ça parce que c'est pas hypocrite non non
on a été hypocrite du tout je veux vous
expliquer pourquoi madame vandriesse
nous explique quelles affaires que le
groupe l'est républicain en ont eu une
position claire non vous n'avez pas eu
une position claire madame vous avez une
position totalement hypocrite je vais
vous dire pourquoi
dans la délibération et je m'assume
parfaitement dans la vie libération qui
nous a été présentée au vote il y avait
pas uniquement l'augmentation moi je
suis intervenu pour dire que je
regrettais 7 aux yeux même proposé
clients une baisse mais dans la
délibération qui nous étaient proposées
y avait pas uniquement l'augmentation
des indemnités il y avait aussi les
sanctions financières pour les élus qui
pratiquent l'absentéisme donc en aucun
cas moi je suis 35 ans je suis et voilà
je suis pour une pour s'occuper de vous
avez accepté tout le temps quelqu'un
parce que c'est un vote global madame
vous savez très bien que dans le rapport
il y avait quatre points différents
qu'on fait si bien pas trop facile à
noircir d'hypocrisie les rémunérés
soient tendres avec votre micro c'est
parfaitement matière en matière d'
hypocrisie les républicains n'ont rien à
envier aux socialistes parce que vous
avez effectivement vous êtes monté au
créneau vous allez jouer les vierges
effarouchées en disant c'est scandaleux
un euro c'est tout sauf que quand on
regarde l'installation du conseil
départemental de côte-d'or présidée par
dessus sauvadet monsieur sauvadet a fait
exactement en avril 2015 la même chose
que madame buffet il est allé au plafond
qui est autorisé par la loi parce que
y'a plafond autorisé par la loi
concernant les indemnités des
conseillers départementaux et là c'était
marrant parce que c'est l inverse
c'était des élus socialistes qui
proposaient des amendements disant il
faut descendre les indemnités parce
qu'en période de son équipe avait rien
du tout madame ces grèves sont les mêmes
proportions et vous le savez très bien
la loi est la même concernant les
plafonds pour les pour les conseillers
départementaux et pour les comptines et
régionaux mais là encore c'est un jeu
d'hypocrite
on sait très bien je les rappelle à
madame du fait dans mon intervention que
la quasi-totalité des commentaires des
élus qui siègent au conseil régional de
franche comté pour un certain d'entre
eux effectivement des professions à côté
bourru mais la quasi-totalité lac lapsus
révélateur la quasi totalité des élus
qui siègent ont déjà des mandats à côté
soit ils sont mères soit ils sont vice
président d'une communauté
d'agglomération soit ils sont maire vice
d'agglomération je suis excité madame
gratuitement au concert
d'après ses filiales et redit par mon
opposition de droite et d'extrême droite
qu'il y avait eu deux postures cette
affaire là moi j'ai voulu avoir une
bonne youssef voulu avoir une posture de
vérité et des fois affronter le débat
effectivement ça veut pas dire être
vouloir toujours être majorité c'est un
format des indemnités c'était largement
suffisant
j'ai voulu absolument avoir un débat sur
la dignité de la fonction d'élu et elle
passe par une disponibilité à son
présentation des membres du ce
ça vient que je peux pas moduler entre
les uns les autres
il a fallu faire un paquet global c'est
peut-être ça le sujet faudrait peut-être
aussi les faire travailler sur alors une
autre avait plus une autre décision a
beaucoup beaucoup fait parler c'est
l'augmentation de la carte grise le
cheval fiscal était à 36 euros en
franche comté en bourgogne il était à 51
ans je me trouve pas ce geste je cite
ces chiffres de tête
résultat ce fut mon talent parlais tout
à l'heure les francs-comtois voit une
augmentation de ce qu'on a fait vous
avez fait un alignement par le haut ils
vont payer 17 millions supplémentaires
est-ce que ça aussi après l'indemnité
des élus qui augmente
est-ce que c'était pas quand même
quelque chose que vous auriez pu éviter
parce que ça va rester des tâches
indélébiles
au cours de votre mandat écoutez moi cet
hymne semblera une tache indélébile au
cours de mon mandat c'est que je ne
remplissent pas mes engagements
c'est que je ne fasse pas sur le plan de
l'emploi sur le plan de la transition
énergétique sur le plan de la culture ce
que je me suis engagé à faire pour cela
il ya besoin de moyens dans un temps où
les budgets publics sont extrêmement
contraint vous n'auriez pas aligné dans
le bain donc ma non parce que j'ai
besoin d'eux ait besoin de sous j'ai
besoin de ses moyens si je veux mener
des projets à dimension stratégique pour
la région bourgogne france-comté
absolument besoin on va ferrer à g votre
opposition rapidement sur ce point là et
puis on passera un chiffre que vous avez
cités si je peux me permettre
vous avez dit que c'était 77 euros
supplémentaires je crois pour une
voiture de 12000 euros
on change à peu près tous les cinq ans
est-ce qu'elles aient de quoi crier au
loup
oui mais d'abord revient toujours trouvé
le problème c'est que nous aussi la
cause alignement on avait proposé de le
faire autrement de moduler et surtout de
générer des économies
deuxièmement vous êtes je parle bien sûr
d'affronter dans une région où il ya un
impact et automobiles réel vous savez
très bien qu'il ya des entre autres la
marque peugeot et dont une rotation une
voiture qui est plus important parce
qu'un système d'achat et de revente etc
ce temps donc on n'est pas non plus sur
des usages de voitures en particulier
dans cette région kasich si vous voulez
puis la troisième chose monsieur nous a
expliqué donc le premier vice président
à la dernière session que royalement il
avait récupéré des économies de 10 mille
euros de frais téléphoniques en ayant
fait un appel d'offres sur les frais des
élus
alors qu'aujourd'hui sur le budget d'un
milliard trois le budget de
fonctionnement n'est pas réellement en
baisse les économies générées sur la
fameuse fusion sur laquelle vous
travaillez madame depuis plus d'un an et
demi ne génère pas d'économie et ses
débuts c'est l'investissement qui vont
être comme d'habitude les variables
d'ajustement
donc ces valses ou si c'est mentir et
investissent comment aujourd'hui ondam
lentement aujourd'hui hit parade des
hommes du feu laissez moi terminer avec
une dotation de l'état dont on sait qui
va diminuer ça c'est structurel vous le
savez vous ajustez par l'augmentation de
l'impôt et on n'est pas réellement dans
une dans une démarche réelle dynamique
de deux générations
aujourd'hui seules les communes de
gosses avenante leur fiscalité tout leur
corps dénudé à dijon
le confluent mais enfin ces cinq
communes de droite qui ont augmenté de
façon absolument continuer à monter tu
l'as long gone je vous parlais aux
questions de droit au togo
s'ils n'ont pas généré sur votre mandat
qu'elle ressent car on ne vous prenez
part à pied projet voulons nous pour
notre région bourgogne france-comté vous
voyez vous une raison qui sortent par le
haut ils ont un savant licence de feu en
matière technologique en matière
industrielle et pour cela nous avons
besoin d'accompagner de façon
structurelle
avant d'entamer la cérémonie non non
vous parlez moi le budget le but il a
gagné nagero 0 jeunes passionnés des
banques je vous en passe ou sheila le
bal va commencer dans quelques jours il
y avait une dotation qui était fait pour
les bacheliers cabine mention très bien
vous l'avez divisé par deux quels sont
vos vous donner à la jeunesse quel
symbole vous donner demain pour
l'investissement sur les jeunes sur la
formation l'apprentissage quand vous
prenez ce genre des dispositions qui
sont symboliques
c'est pas une histoire de budget trouver
les budgets d'économies sur les
dotations ou sur les mentions pour les
bacheliers très bien et qu'il obtienne
une mention très bien et trouver des
économies ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya des symboles forts
vous avez été en décalage sur
l'augmentation des élus vous étendez
gallas soit mais sachons vous donner au
jeu et je suis en décalage quand je
commente l'aide bienvenue dans le viseur
signature aux nantais dont permis de
conduire pour les jeunes et aux moins de
26 ans et qui ont besoin effectivement
de c'est peut-être parce que ils n'ont
pas de maisons brûlées vous étiez
laurent à montréal et bien et c'est
fondamental pour leur recherche d'emploi
s'étaient d'existant bourgogne elle est
étendue à la franche comté depuis le
mois d'avril
ça fait partie de ces mesures de
convergence les bacheliers
il ya une mesure au niveau national
c'est pas moi qui les diminuer c'est au
niveau national d'une décision qu'elle
en a c'est une majorité social via les
leaders au niveau national d'art est
effectivement un certain nombre de
bourses au mérite mais pour pouvoir
augmenter les bourses pour les personnes
les plus en difficulté donc ça a été un
choix incomparable faire réagir ce film
ont-elles par rapport à cette
augmentation de la carte grise vous avez
pensé quoi et
nous avons nous avons évidemment voté
contre parce que on a quand même eu le
sentiment très clair depuis
l'installation du nouveau conseil
régional bourgogne franche comté que les
francs comtois était un peu les narines
la farce quoi c'est pas vrai pour les
deux permis dont on parle on parle on
parle de 17 millions d'euros qui vont
être fonctionner directement dans les
poches des francs comtois et pas dans
les poches des bourguignons et moi la
sensation est un pays mais nous oui mais
la science il ya réajustement monté
l'association la sensation que j'ai et
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
très clairement vous avez dit vous avez
besoin d'argent a besoin de recettes
supplémentaires pour mener à bien tous
vos projets et vos projets qui consiste
essentiellement à faire augmenter de
manière exponentielle les charges de
fonctionnement par rapport aux dépenses
d'investissement qui alors vous me
parler je vous ai entendu mais je trouve
il faut tordre le cou à ce genre
d'arguments ça devient insupportable
les présidents de conseils régionaux les
exécutifs en général ont tendance à
expliquer non non vous savez quand on
vote les budgets l'investissement est
toujours en hausse sauf que madame
buffet vous savez il ya des comptes
administratifs après et à l'exécution
des budgets
donc quand on regarde la différence
entre le compte administratif est les
propositions de budget sont des
prévisionnels dans les budgets on
s'aperçoit et c'est la règle générale
que les exécutifs soient de gauche ou
soit de droite que les budgets
d'investissement exécutés sont en baisse
par rapport au prévisionnel qui est
présenté au moment du budget est parfois
je voulais vrai les projets ne sont pas
non plus ne dépende s'adonner ou ne
rentrait pas dans des considérations
techniques là je voulais vous interrogez
madame du febvre on a besoin on parlait
je parle des charges de fonctionnement
qui vont qui ont qui augmentent de
manière exponentielle depuis une dizaine
d'années dans les collectivités telus au
ciel on va parler des charges de
personnel et des charges de personnel
parce que moi je
je vais moins souvent très régional de
dijon mais je vais encore régulièrement
cancer national de besançon
je filme des derniers résistants
d'ailleurs et j'entends il ya des agents
qui viennent me voir en m'expliquant que
voilà il ya des problèmes il ya des
problèmes notamment dans les chu de la
commande y aller je veux pas parler de
dérive lancera en tout cas il ya des
choses inquiétantes en termes de
dépenses des frais de déplacement des
agents
il paraît que les enveloppes commencent
à augmenter de manière assez
significative donc manger une petite
suggestion
ce serait de très rapidement mettre en
place votre organigramme et de
stabiliser les agents parce que pour
l'instant tout le monde est dans le flou
artistique
les uns et les autres se demandent s'ils
vont devoir aller travailler à dijon
restait à besançon faire des navires de
choses vous verrez pas lancer dans
l'organisation jusqu'à maintenant donc
l'organisation s'est faite par le ou les
les grands responsables ont été choisis
et puis ça doit descendre en cascade dit
s'ils le souhaitent emprunter de plus
après il ya les graves par un dialogue
social et puis après il ya les histoires
de déplacement parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'entre dijon et besançon
ça circule beaucoup dans les deux sens
par avoir aidé au cactus d'ailleurs en
direction de vision que dans l'autre
sens
et puis écouter alors soit on décide que
tous les agents vont être à dijon où que
tous les agents vont être à besançon
décide ça et à ce moment là y'a plus de
déplacements soit on décide d'une
organisation équilibrée
c'est ce qui a été décidé par l'état
l'année dernière et qui est décidé
aujourd'hui par la région que je préside
une organisation équilibre entre
besançon et dijon
ça nécessite effectivement des
déplacements alors se sont pas tous les
agents qui ceux qui se déplacent c'est
essentiellement les agents d'encadrement
effectivement donc c'est assez parlant
des merlas mans que vous allez pouvoir
faire des économies
comment on peut rechercher un équilibre
et ne pas avoir de déplacement la seule
façon d'éviter les déplacements une
répartition de service
la seule façon d'éviter les déplacements
c'est d'avoir effectivement des agents
qui va activement massivement aller sur
un site au détriment de l'autre ça je ne
le veux pas et je me suis engagé depuis
le début à ce qu'il n'y ait pas par sa
mobilisation toujours influent
grâce il ya toujours un flou dans les
services quand est ce qu'il reste de
foule attendait le flou dans les
services
vous savez quand une entreprise des
rebeus entreprises fusionnent deux
organisations fusionnent ya quand même
toujours du flou et c'est normal écoutez
non non non ça fait sud loire et la
loire
ces six mois et la loi nous amènerait
2004 la loi nous impose la fusion de la
loi nous impose de délibérer au mois de
juin prochain sur l'organisation de
cette région dont une année de la
session nous allons délibérer au mois de
juin prochain sur l'organisation
l'organisation qui est parallèle à celle
de l'état et ça veut dire qu'il y aura
des directions à dijon qu'il y aura des
directions à besançon avec elle c'est
pas que la plupart des directions
c'est absolument clair jusqu'à
maintenant on ne pouvait pas trop
communiquer dessus parce que nous étions
dialogue social et moi je tiens à ce que
le dialogue social il soit franc est
vraiment ce dialogue social a eu lieu il
ya trois jours
la répartition elle est effectivement
celle que j'ai proposé beaucoup de
directions opérationnelles
à besançon en miroir de celle de l'état
l'économie la formation les transitions
professionnelles
la transition énergétique les lycées
parce qu'il y a au niveau de l'état
les directions les services déconcentrés
des ministères qui sont à besançon il y
a eu ce choix l'année dernière du
gouvernement de mettre la direccte la
dréal le rectorat coordonnateur à
besançon du coup à dijon nous avons
d'autres directions plus fonctionnel
qu'opérationnel les finances les
ressources humaines mais aussi les
transports d'autant plus que dijon
vraiment le noeud au niveau des
transports sev ne ferroviaire c'est très
important
la culture l'agriculture le tourisme
tout cela va va témoigner d'une
recherche d' équilibre qui est celle que
j'ai toujours voulu pour cette région
il votera qu'ucb votre cabinet à
besançon
vous physiquement on va alors moi
physiquement je vais vous expliquer je
suis toujours je suis deux jours à
besançon deux jours à dijon est en
théorie le jour du milieu sur toute la
région sauf que le jour du milieu il a
tendance à déborder ce dont je me
félicite
je suis plutôt un jour a besoin sans un
jour à dijon et le reste du temps tu sur
le terrain et exhortons la 18 à dijon
ils se plaignent de ne pas me voir enfin
écoutez moi je les vois pas non plus la
non excusez-moi mais franchement je suis
à dijon de façon équilibrée à besançon
je couche d'ailleurs excusé moi
deux fois par semaine à dijon où il ya
la possibilité de relance dans une de
vos équipiers à la possibilité pour
l'ensemble dès élus de la région de
pouvoir profiter d'un d'un bénéficier
d'un appartement qui est dans des locaux
de la région
il est ouvert à aux élus qui bouge
beaucoup et effectivement j'en profite
en général deux fois personnelles donc
vous démonter le fait d'être ce que
dénoncent certains élit le fait que vous
ne soyez jamais à dijon à nous selon
l'asfc
après ce référendum la même présidente
comme tous les élus aujourd'hui le font
dans des exécutifs c'est juste la
modernité et puis en plus la
transparence se fait montel vous avez
demandé la parole parce que je chante en
commentaire la réponse de la présidente
de marivent marie-guite dufay
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que la
commission des finances on a eu à
travailler la semaine dernière soit un
document qui effectivement n'était
absolument pas finalisé on nous a
présenté un organigramme sans nous dire
aujourd'hui vous apporter des précisions
sont nous dire exactement
l'arrivée de venise aujourd'hui c'est de
l'europe a retiré avec des informations
fraîches et votre premier vice président
monsieur neugnot nous a juste expliqué
42% à besançon par 58 à dijon c'est l'
équilibre
drôle de contrôle de conception par
rapport aux savourer la taille de la
région ces deux produits vous avouerez
que c'est assez particulier mais encore
une fois vous avez voulu la fusion j'ai
eu l'occasion de vous dire à plusieurs
reprises vous en assumer aujourd'hui les
désagréments et
et les numéros des crises dans cette
recherche d'une organisation qui est
extrêmement compliqué je voudrais quand
même tordre le cou à une idée reçue à un
commentaire que j'entends régulièrement
à savoir celle panique à bord
je peux vous dire qu'au niveau de
l'administration des deux
administrations bourgogne et franche
comté il ya des interrogations légitimes
nous sommes en train de les travailler
mais il ya aussi une envie d'aller de
l'avant une appétence une découverte
mutuelle que pour faire face à des
questions identiques ya eu des
recherches de solutions différentes
du coup ça crée de l'émulation et de la
stimulation il ya une vraie envie de
travailler en ce sens donc c'est à moi
je vois dans l'administration avait
compliqué ça marchait très bien la
coopération entre la bourgogne et la
franche-comté n'y avait pas besoin de
fusion va pas refaire le match là on va
pas refaire le match
il ya eu des fusions avec plus de
régions dans d'autres régions de 2 3 4
et jour et aujourd'hui
duchaussoy en état de fonctionnement par
les laisser le temps est probablement
une des régions les plus au clair et les
plus en avance dans son organisation
et ça c'est grâce au travail de
préfiguration que nous avions fait alors
vous avez fait votre choix vous allez
proposer donc le 24 juin que ce soit
besançon qui soit le siège du conseil
régional de l'hôtel de région
alors que dijon et la capitale régionale
est ce que c'est un peu ridicule
finalement ce débat c'est un peu comme
si l'elysée était à paris mais le
gouvernement et l'assemblée était à lyon
ou à marseille
est-ce que c'était pas plus logique de
tout rassembler quand même sur un même
si c'est conforme à deux choses d'abord
balaie d'abord dit un fort mal équilibre
que j'ai voulu et dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure
et effectivement conforme à la loi parce
que la loi dit elle même on ne peut pas
mettre au même endroit la préfecture de
région
le siège des assemblées et le siège de
l'hôtel de région
sauf à aller chercher les trois
cinquièmes des voix de l'assemblée ça
prouve bien que la loi est là d'abord
en compte cette nécessité d' équilibre
dans les nouvelles régions fusionner et
regarder ce qui se passe en normandie ou
rouen et caen sont d'ailleurs un peu
plus éloigné que besançon et dijon mais
c'est un peu le même système ou mourants
et la préfecture où caen accueillera
l'hôtel de région où même les assemblées
seront au havre - je suis partisane de
cet équilibre c'est un signe qui est
envoyé et à besançon qui perd son statut
de capitale régionale qui perd son
statut de préfecture de région
et c'est un signe qui est envoyé à
l'ensemble du territoire parce que s'il
y a quelque chose que je veux absolument
réussir pendant ce mandat c'est la
conjonction d'une grande région et d'une
politique de proximité en territorialise
en eau politique c'est à dire en allant
au plus près des initiatives des uns et
des autres et cela nécessite
effectivement cet équilibre vie d'anne
sophie monter vous allez voter pour
je vois pas la cohérence de votre air
c'est un vote politique je constate moi
que dijon a eu tendance à absorber
énormément dans la fusion c'est la
capitale c'est la capitale régionale il
y à la préfecture de région qui est à
dijon donc partir du moment où on
augmente en plus la taxe sur les
certificats d'immatriculation pour les
franc comtois certes c'est une mesure
symbolique moi je j'aurai l'occasion
d'ailleurs de le rappeler au mois de
juin il ya quand même des sujets qui
sont autrement plus graves que de savoir
où sera le siège et l'assemblée
délibérante
à partir du moment où dijon a déjà
énormément de choses on l'a vu on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure encore avec cette
répartition 42 58%
concernant les services moi j'estime
tout à fait logique que le siège
institutionnels reviennent à besançon
semaine ya rien qui me sens même si
c'est une coquille vide parce que les
commissions les commissions permanentes
expressions comme je vous parle de douze
directions opérationnelles et les
commissions vont se réunir à dijon les
commissions permanentes aussi en
permanence est liée à l'assemblée donc
ça c'est quand même plutôt du bon sens
de faire venir les icônes et les
nivernais
là où on sent donc ce ne sera pas
évident n'a absolument pas et moi je
plaiderai surtout et je jeu j'utiliserai
toute mon énergie et la place qui est la
mienne pour que besançon et dijon qui
n'ont jamais travaillé ensemble dans
deux régions à qui se tournaient le dos
puis maintenant pour la survie des
enfants organisée je parle de la volonté
politique des deux magistrats qui
veulent mer dont ils veulent mettre en
place dix jours 1 pour le micro place de
tous ces bobos et zou je pousserai
beaucoup à cette notion de pôles
métropolitains pour que les initiatives
prises notamment au niveau économique
par les deux maires puissent
effectivement se faire en synergie
carreno oui parce que moi je suis la
seule de leurs représentantes en tout
cas bourguignonne et dijonnaise aussi
alors sous les cheveux entendre sur ce
que dit eric sicaud bonne et franche
comté puisque nous sommes sur france
comptait 10 toutes les choses en réalité
c'est l'exécutif politique qui va être
basé à besançon politique là où les
choses se décident de se fondre et c'est
pas simplement symbolique de la présence
géographique ça va au delà exécutif on
lui a dit jean-louis non mais l'accord
dans les assemblées dans la manière dont
les choses sont faites et gérer au
quotidien les décisions politiques et
décisions importantes elles vont être
prises jur graphiquement à besançon en
lisant collégialité elles sont
pénalisées dans votre bureau ce qui est
normal vous êtes la présidente d'un
exécutant prise abusive et deuxième
chose vraiment elle il va falloir que
vous expliquez à vos électeurs de ma
région qui ont voté pour vos candidats
je vous rappelle que les suffrages les
sélections régionales is war 2 et s vous
savez quand tout journaliste jason bay
bicéphale a maudit départementale et
communale interrompre systématiquement
vous l'a pas mal de gens vont alors je
vous interromps pas si vous avez donc
par tous leurs concerts vous convient
pas vous interrompez on a été lu tous
par rapport à notre représentation
territoriale sur des listes
départementales
c'est le scrutin régional et vous
avez-vous malade mental pris la décision
de batik 1 parce que je pense pas qu'une
liberté de vote dans votre groupe
politique de voter certains dimanches
d'été certainement à 100% avec des élus
bourguignon va je trouve ça assez engagé
vis-à-vis de votre électorat va pas
voter de manière visible non parce que
c'est une liberté de ton vis-à-vis de
votre électorat qui s'est prononcé sur
des sur des suffrages dans des
territoires ddt expliqué qu'aujourd'hui
vous considérez normal que l'exécutif
soit sachez en fait sur un mode très
politique et très dogmatique de fonds
national et on va se retrouver en
réalité au match loin dans une union fn
ps dans les questions aujourd'hui
pas sûr que tu fais est ce matin je vais
vous répondre tout de suite en
commission permanente aux élus ont voté
99% des rapports présentés par les
socialistes ce qui n'est pas le cas du
front national s'il vous plaît l'on veut
arrêter avec cela
arrêtez avec le mps est une réalité pour
celui alors sur le sur le volet fait
qu'il vous m'expliquer que pendant les
élections régionales les électeurs qui
se sont déplacés pour aller voter front
national ont voté alem pour la
motivation qui était de savoir que le
front national proposait tel ou tel
candidat mais vous rigolez mais vous
rigolez encore ils ont voté front
national absolument pas thérèse enclavé
d'à sur internet à voter votre groupe
libérés ça veut dire que les dijonnais
vont voter contre et qu' il y aura
certainement des positions je comprend
l'attachement territoriales
fo ne soyons pas soyons sérieux sur le
sujet dont on comprend l'attachement
territoriales par contre la position
même du fait qu'ils étaient quand même
quelque chose qui était stratégiquement
je pense là par contre est anticipée est
annoncée au fil de l'eau c'est ça qu'on
reproche mais il y en avait dégradé mais
fait je suis posé le débat mais un
départ très important oui effectivement
il y avait un peu compliqué ce qu'on
peut appeler cette fracture territoriale
ya eu débat maintenant les sauces ont
tranché elle sera soudée et ma marge et
et elle est soudée autour d'alain
vautier donner à votre devoir est long
mais voilà
en tout cas ce qu'on peut conclure c'est
que madame monte elle parle de
résistance des 1 comtois par amour aux
bourguignons madame von trier se parlent
d'attachement territoria c'est pas gagné
1 d'être des de la france les
conseillers régionaux construire un
petit à petit à se construire à petit at
il effectivement elle se construira
petit à petit donc on vous donne
rendez-vous dans quelques minutes après
le journal présenté par par clément jana
qui donc vous présentera l'édition en
virage augmenté de la mi-journée en
franche comté
vous aurez bien sûr c'est une édition en
bourgogne on se retrouve après le
journal en deuxième partie
et puis vous avez bien compris il faudra
suivre attentivement la cession du 24
juin au nous verrons comment voteront
les uns et les autres justement sur
cette histoire de siège du conseil
régional basé à besançon
c'est une proposition de marie-guite
dufay et on verra comment réagir les
différentes compote à tout ses états